>> Sean: THE RECOUNT CONTINUES
TONIGHT IN FLORIDA.
FIRST, ACCORDING TO NEW REPORTS,
SENATOR LINDSEY GRAHAM MAY BE
THE NEXT CHAIR OF THE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE AS SENATOR GRASSLEY
WEIGHS HIS DEPARTURE, INCREASING
THE CHANCES OF A FULL
INVESTIGATION INTO THE FBI,
THEIR HANDLING OF THE CLINTON
EMAIL PROBE.
JOINING US NOW WITH MORE
REACTION, SOUTH CAROLINA
SENATOR LINDSEY GRAHAM.
GOOD TO SEE YOU.
BEFORE WE GET TO THAT, I WANT TO
ASK YOU ABOUT YOUR THOUGHTS ON
THE RECOUNT AND ALL OF A SUDDEN
80,000 HERE, 15,000 HERE, THEY
JUST KEEP SHOWING UP.
>> IF RICK SCOTT HAD NOT WAITED
IN THE WAY HE IS AND
PRESIDENT TRUMP HAD NOT SPOKEN
UP, I THINK THEY WOULD'VE STOLE
THIS THING FROM US FOR 90
SOMETHING THOUSAND VOTES
COUNTED AFTER THE POLLS CLOSE.
HE STOPPED THE BLEEDING.
IT CANNOT BE OVERCOME BY A
RECOUNT.
I THINK RICK SCOTT IS GOING TO
WIN THIS AND MATHEMATICALLY
NELSON IS ELIMINATED.
THANK GOD PRESIDENT TRUMP AND
RICK SCOTT TOOK THIS SERIOUSLY.
>> Sean: SENATOR, WE HAVE A
LOT OF JUDICIAL APPOINTMENTS.
WE HAVE THE THREAT BY JEFF FLAKE
ABOUT PROTECTING YOUR LETTER.
I KNOW YOU SAID THAT IS FINE,
BUT THE PRESIDENT SAID HE HAS NO
INTENTION OF FIRING MUELLER.
SOME AGREEMENT HAS BEEN MADE BY
THE REPORTS I READ BETWEEN THE
PRESIDENT'S LAWYERS AND THE
SPECIAL COUNSEL, WRITTEN
ANSWERS.
THAT MEANS THIS IS COME TO AN
END, AT LEAST IN MY MIND.
>> THIS IS A MANUFACTURED
PROBLEM.
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS NOT GOING TO
FIRE IS BENIGN.
WE NEED CONSERVATIVE JUDGES ON
THE BENCH, AS MANY AS WE CAN.
I DO NOT KNOW WHAT
SENATOR GRASSLEY WILL BE DOING.
IF I'M CHAIRMAN, WE ARE GOING TO
DO JUDGES, JUDGES, AND MORE
JUDGES.
AT THE END OF THE DAY, I WILL BE
CONVINCED THAT MR. MUELLER WILL
DO HIS JOB.
I HAVE NOT SEEN ONE SCINTILLA OF
EVIDENCE OF COLLUSION, THE
OBSTRUCTION OF JUSTICE DID NOT
MAKE SENSE TO ME.
YOU CAN FIRE SOMEBODY WHO WORKS
AS A POLITICAL EMPLOYMENT, THE
FBI DIRECTOR CAN BE FIRED FOR
ALMOST ANY REASON.
THE DEMOCRATS WANTED COMEY
FIRED.
I FEEL GOOD ABOUT EVERYTHING
RIGHT NOW.
>> Sean: AT MANY THINGS, IT
WAS A KEY MOMENT AT THE
KAVANAUGH HEARINGS WHEN YOU
SPOKE UP.
IT WAS A POWERFUL MOMENT AND AN
IMPORTANT ONE IN TERMS OF WHAT
WAS GOING ON.
ONE OF THE PEOPLE THAT MADE THE
MOST OUTRAGEOUS CLAIMS WAS
MICHAEL AVENATTI.
HE'S FACING SERIOUS CHARGES
TONIGHT.
BUT THAT STORY, WE NOW KNOW, IT
CHANGED WITH THE CLIENT HE WAS
REPRESENTING.
IT CHANGED PRETTY DRAMATICALLY
IN TERMS OF WHAT SHE SAID.
HE MADE THESE ACCUSATIONS, AND
AS I'VE BEEN PLAYING, I'M NOT
SAYING THIS -- I BELIEVE IN DUE
PROCESS AND THE PRESUMPTION OF
INNOCENCE.
ESPECIALLY WITH SERIOUS CHARGES.
IT HAS SERVED THIS COUNTRY SO
WELL.
TO NOT BE CONSISTENT, MAKE ME A
HYPOCRITE, I AM ASSISTANT.
BUT I WONDER IF YOU HAVE
THOUGHTS TONIGHT.
>> NUMBER ONE, MS. SWEATNICK'S
CHARGES MADE NO SENSE.
WHY WOULD YOU KEEP PUTTING
YOURSELF AT RISK?
THE CLAIM BY MS. SWEAT NICK THAT
WAS AUTHORED BY MR. MENOTTI
HELPED US BECAUSE IT WAS OVER
THE TOP.
SEEMS LIKE A CREDIBLE
ALLEGATION, BUT HE'S ENTITLED TO
THE PRESUMPTION OF INNOCENCE.
I WILL GIVE HIM THAT DO.
I'M NOT OUT TO GIVE MR. AVENATTI
BY TURNING THE LEGAL SYSTEM
UPSIDE DOWN.
>> LET'S STAY WITH THAT.
YOU SAID YOU ARE READY, PERHAPS,
TO REOPEN THE HILLARY EMAIL
INVESTIGATION.
WE KNOW THE DEMOCRATS IN THE
HOUSE, THEY'VE BEEN DOING
HUNDREDS OF DIFFERENT
INVESTIGATIONS.
WHY DO YOU TALK ABOUT CLINTON?
DO WE HAVE EQUAL JUSTICE OF THE
LAW, EQUAL APPLICATION UNDER THE
LAW?
THAT WOULD BE AN EXONERATION
BEFORE AN INVESTIGATION IN THE
CASE OF HILLARY CLINTON.
THAT WOULD MEAN IF WE ARE GOING
TO TALK ABOUT RUSSIA AND RUSSIAN
INFLUENCE, THAT HAS TO GO TO THE
DOSSIER.
BOUGHT AND PAID FOR, FUNNELED
MONEY INTO A LAW FIRM INTO AN OP
RESEARCH GROUP, A FOREIGN
NATIONAL.
THE BUNK LIES THE AUTHOR
WOULDN'T EVEN STAND BY WHEN
PRESSED IN AN INTERROGATORY IN
GREAT BRITAIN.
THEN, THE LEAKING OF SUCH
INFORMATION TO INFLUENCE THE
2016 ELECTIONS, LIES ABOUT
DONALD TRUMP PAID FOR FROM
RUSSIA.
OF COURSE, BEING USED TO APPOINT
A SPECIAL COUNSEL.
IT IS ALL OF THAT ON THE TABLE
FOR YOU?
>> YOU KNOW, I PUT TO MY
DEMOCRATIC FRIENDS, IF WE LOOK
BACKWARDS, WE ARE ALL GOING TO
LOOK BACKWARDS.
I WANT TO KNOW IF THE FBI
REACHED WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE THAT HILLARY CLINTON
DIDN'T COMMIT A CRIME.
IF YOU REALLY WANTED TO STOP
TRUMP, HOW IN THE WORLD COULD
YOU INDICT HER?
WAS THE REASON SHE WASN'T
INDICTED WAS BECAUSE THEY WANTED
TO MAKE SURE THEY STOP TRUMP AND
HOW CAN YOU STOP HIM IF YOU
INDICT SPEED
HER?
THAT THEY USE A DOCUMENT PAID
FOR BY THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY?
RESEARCH BY FOREIGN AGENTS TO
GET A WARRANT AGAINST AN
AMERICAN CITIZEN THAT WAS
INAPPROPRIATE, POTENTIALLY
UNLAWFUL?
WE NEED A SPECIAL COUNSEL TO
LOOK AT ALL OF THIS.
BUT I INTEND TO LOOK AT IT.
IF YOU ARE GOING TO KEEP PLOWING
EVERYTHING UP IN 2016, COUNT ME
IN.
IF YOU WANT TO LOOK FOR IT, I
WILL LOOK FOR IT.
IF YOU WANT TO LOOK BACK, WE
WILL ALL LOOK BACK TO EVERYTHING
AND EVERYBODY.
NOT JUST A TRUMP.
>> Sean: I FORGOT ABOUT THE
FISA COURT, THE BULK OF
INFORMATION CAME FROM THE PHONY,
UNVERIFIED, UNCORROBORATED
DOSSIER THAT HAS MOSTLY BEEN
DEBUNKED.
A PROPOSAL TODAY FROM THE
WHITE HOUSE ABOUT PRISON REFORM.
WE ALSO THE VIDEO OF ALICE MARIE
JOHNSON, ONE DEFENSE, SERIOUS,
22 YEARS IN JAIL, RACED OUT TO
THE ARMS OF HER FAMILY.
IT WAS BEYOND A TOUCHING MOMENT.
SAID THANK YOU, AMERICA, FOR
GIVING ME A SECOND CHANCE WHEN
THE PRESIDENT PARTED HER.
I LOOK AT PRISON REFORM.
WE'VE GOT 2 MILLION PEOPLE IN
JAIL.
IN A FIVE-YEAR PERIOD, 77%
RECIDIVISM RATE.
I WANT TO FIND EVERY ALICE MARIE
JOHNSON IN AMERICA AND I'D LOVE
THE PRESIDENT TO PART IN ONE
SUCH PERSON, TEN PEOPLE A DAY IF
WE CAN DO THAT, BECAUSE I THINK
WE DO NEED REAL REFORM.
THERE IS UNFAIRNESS IN THE
SYSTEM.
>> YES.
WOULDN'T IT BE IRONIC IF IT WAS
DONALD TRUMP WHO FIXED THE
PROBLEMS CREATED BY THE THREE
STRIKES YOU'RE OUT RULE PASSED
BY BILL CLINTON?
WOULDN'T IT BE IRONIC IT WAS
DONALD TRUMP AND THE REPUBLICAN
CONGRESS WORKING WITH DEMOCRATS
THAT ALLOWED JUST THOUSANDS OF
AFRICAN-AMERICAN AND HISPANIC
MALES A SECOND CHANCE FOR
NONVIOLENT OFFENSES?
CREATE THAT SPACE --
>> Sean: PUNISHMENT IS NOT
WORKING.
IF YOU HAVE A 77% RECIDIVISM
RATE, LOCKING YOU UP IN A PLACE
WITH BAD PEOPLE AND NOT HELPING
OR ADVANCING AND CHANGING HEARTS
AND MINDS, IT MAKES SENSE TO ME.
BUT SENATOR, WILL FOLLOW THAT
MORE.
I THINK THERE IS A LOT OF
POTENTIAL THERE.
IMAGINE THE PRESIDENT
TRANSFORMING THE POWER OF THE
PARDON FOR EVERY ALICE MARIE
JOHNSON WHO I MET AND IS AN
AMAZING WOMAN.
I THINK IT WOULD BE GREAT FOR
THE COUNTRY.
>> GETTING MINORITIES OUT OF